[Music]  my name is omar rutledge  when i was 19 i was an infantry soldier  during the u.s invasion of iraq  i found that returning home was just the  beginning of my challenges  everything seemed totally different even  though it all looked the same  somehow the war changed me  but how  and why  when i got out of the army i wanted to  understand how experiencing trauma  changes the brain and more importantly  to try to develop better treatments to  help people get back to normal  this inspired me to become a  neuroscientist  as a graduate student at mit i'm  learning how to investigate the brain  through magnetic resonance imaging or  mri  i am designing a clinical trial to  investigate if the alternative medicine  cbd has an effect on social anxiety  disorder the most common anxiety  disorder in the u.s  my hope is this research will allow us  to better understand the effects of this  drug and how it may be useful for the  treatment of mental health conditions  [Music]